[Music]
welcome back to CBS mornings where we
are talking about yet another Republican
getting a little bit closer to running
for president South Carolina Senator Tim
Scott you've seen him on the show well
he launched an exploratory committee
yesterday drawing contrast between
himself and the leading GOP Contender
you may have heard of him Donald Trump
Scott gave his first Network interview
as a potential candidate to CBS News
we're happy about that and caitly
Caitlin Huey Burns spoke with the
senator in Iowa after his announcement
I'm announcing my exploratory committee
for president of the United States for
weeks Senator Tim Scott has been on a
tour of key political States now he's
betting in the race for the Republican
Presidential nomination optimism wins
over outrage even as Donald Trump leads
the field I see that America is starving
for positive optimistic leadership if we
can unite this country around the
solutions focusing more on those
Solutions than anything else it's my
only path forward and it's the one I've
chosen is your candidate see a sign that
the Republican party needs new
leadership well I hope that the nation
wants new leadership I happen to be a
conservative because it actually works
it's one of the reasons why I went from
a poor kid married in poverty in a
single parent household to to a person
who was able to start my own business
and then run for Congress his
announcement stands in stark contrast to
the former president's message our
country is going to hell
willing to criticize Trump directly or
by name I'm not focused on politicians
I'll be honest with you but I've heard
from the American people that they want
us to focus on them not on each other if
Donald Trump is the nominee for the
Republican Party would you support him I
plan on being the nominee obviously I
have an exploratory committee moving
forward but if Trump is the nominee
would you support him obviously I'm
looking forward to being the nominee in
that Quest for the nomination Scott
would be joining fellow South Carolinian
Nikki Haley who also spent Wednesday in
Iowa Scott is the Senate's only black
Republican and has put an emphasis on
faith and conservative values I am
certainly 100 pro-life without any
question I've been very very clear about
that very uh consistent about that I do
think we spend not enough time
understanding how far the far left has
gone on the issue of abortion if you
were president would you advocate for
federal
limits yeah so once again I once again
I'm 100 pro-life and I I do believe yes
that and that's not what I said I do
believe that we should have a robust
conversation about what's happening in
the on a very important topic Scott says
his personal story sets him apart from
the rest of the GOP field his mother
sacrifices Center to a likely campaign
so when you told your mom that you were
going to make this decision what did she
say I think she kind of cried honestly
yeah I think it's uh wow I couldn't
question myself it's it's amazing to
have such a miserable beginning
and then have a chance to continue to
represent not only your country but your
your family and her sacrifice She's My
Real American Hero first CBS mornings
Caitlin Huey Burns Cedar Rapids Iowa
well he does have a great personal
backstory there's no question about that
and I think when he says what this
country wants is positive optimistic
leadership I think people on both sides
he's not wrong about that and he's got a
compelling story yeah
exploratory committee but he just said I
plan to be the nominee so I think the
exploration's done yeah I do too